in May of 2018 something weird happened
over the Arabian Peninsula a large
cyclone passed over the rubra Holly
desert a massive stretch of unbroken
sand also called The Empty Quarter it
usually looks like this but after the
cyclone it looked like this Lakes had
formed between the dunes the desert was
filled with water
for the first time in 20 years then five
months later it happened again another
cyclone hit over the next year powerful
cyclones kept coming out of the Arabian
Sea at a frequency not seen in decades
it caused catastrophic flooding in
normally dry areas across the region but
especially here in East Africa today the
flood waters have receded but they left
behind a different type of disaster
millions of locusts a plague of biblical
proportions worst in 70 years the impact
devastating precedented threat to food
security is no end in sight this is a
desert locust it's a type of grasshopper
that lives across this area from
northwest Africa to Western Asia
typically desert locust spend most of
their time alone in what's called their
solitary phase they only really meet
with others to mate but if the weather
starts to shift that can lead to a
transformation if a normally dry area
becomes unusually lush with vegetation
as it would after heavy rains these
insects will start to congregate that
sudden crowding triggers a hormone and
the locust starts to change both
physically and mentally it starts with a
color shift from a muddled brown color
to a bright yellow its body shrinks and
its endurance increases which optimizes
it for flight its brain grows and so
does its appetite this is called the
gregarious phase they eat and breathe
leaving their eggs in the damp soil when
they hatch they form what are called
hopper bands swarms of tens of thousands
of non-flying but voracious insects that
move together as a unit
eventually they develop wings and once
they take flight it's almost impossible
to stop them locust swarms ride the wind
which allows them to travel up to a
hundred and fifty kilometers a day a
single swarm can contain up to 150
million insects per square kilometer
each one consumes its body weight and
vegetation daily in 24 hours a swarm of
that size eats more food than 35,000
people since late 2019 East Africa has
been experiencing its worst locust
outbreak in decades in 2020 the area has
seen swarms as large as 2,400 square
kilometres that's a swarm of insects
over three times the size of New York
City capable of eating as much food as
tens of millions of people the swarms of
bugs are so thick that airplanes have
been forced to divert their course
billions of ravenous insects sweep
through areas decimating acres of
farmland and threatening already food
scarce regions with famine there's
nothing left to harvest there's nothing
else that I know how to do and they're
spreading in February Pakistan declared
a state of emergency by late May the
swarms had reached parts of northern
India for the first time since 1962 and
the biggest factor in all this is the
weather locusts reproduce exponentially
when the weather is in their favor with
every new generation the population
increases twenty fold so if a normally
dry area stays wet for a long time the
population will explode and that's what
researchers think happened starting with
a 20-18 cyclone the unusual amount of
rain led to an unusual amount of
vegetation which led to an unusual
number of new locust swarms formed here
in the unusually wet desert and made
their way into surrounding areas
including East Africa which itself had
just experienced historic flooding in
late 2019 from heavy rains caused by an
unusually warm Indian Ocean
a single perfect storm isn't enough to
bring in swarms of locusts of this size
it takes a series of them something that
used to be really rare in this area but
unfortunately extreme weather that used
to be really rare suddenly becoming more
common is one of the hallmarks of
climate change that could mean a future
with more cyclones in the desert more
greenery where there once was sand and
more breeding grounds fellow ghosts do
you ever notice these weirdly specific
targeted ads when you're browsing the
internet it's a little creepy when they
can even pinpoint where you live that's
because one of the ways advertisers
target you is through your IP address
see each of your devices has its own
unique number so while your internet
might be password protected your IP
address is available to advertisers to
look at and that is how they find your
location expressvpn is a tool that mask
your IP address they let you select from
over 90 different countries to reroute
your connection through so it makes it
seem like all your web activity is
coming from a different IP address
somewhere else in the world
one-click not only encrypts your data
but lets you browse the web anonymously
expressvpn does not affect our editorial
but their support does make videos like
this one possible you can go to
expressvpn dot-com slash box or click on
the link in the description below to
find out how to get three months free